Patrick n'a jamais abandonné son rêve d'étudier à l'université.
Tard le soir, après le travail,
il surfait sur le net, cherchant des façons d'étudier.
Voici Debbie.
Debbie est originaire de Floride.
Ses parents ne sont pas allés à l'université,
pas plus que n’importe lesquels de ses frères et sœurs.
Debbie a travaillé toute sa vie,
elle paye des impôts, subvient à ses besoins, jour après jour,
elle est fière de vivre le rêve américain,
un rêve qui reste incomplet
sans éducation supérieure.
Cependant, Debbie n'a pas d'économies pour aller à l'université.
Elle ne peut pas payer les frais de scolarité.
Elle ne peut pas lâcher son boulot.
Voici Wael.
Wael est originaire de Syrie.
Il souffre directement
de la misère, de la peur et des échecs
imposés à son pays.
Il croit fermement à l'éducation.
Il sait que s'il avait l'opportunité
de poursuivre ses études,
une chance de se démarquer,
il aurait une meilleure chance de survivre
dans ce monde sens dessus dessous.
Le système universitaire
a délaissé Patrick, Debbie et Wael,
tout comme il délaisse
des millions d'étudiants potentiels,
qui ont terminé le secondaire,
qui ont la capacité de poursuivre leurs études
et qui veulent étudier,
mais qui ne peuvent y entrer pour diverses raisons.
Principalement à cause de raisons financières.
L'université est très chère. Nous le savons tous.
Dans la majorité des pays du monde,
l'université est inaccessible
pour un citoyen moyen.
C'est probablement le plus gros problème
auquel est confrontée notre société.
L'enseignement supérieur n'est plus un droit universel,
mais est devenu un privilège pour un petit groupe.
La deuxième raison est d'ordre culturel.
Les étudiants qualifiés pour les études supérieures,
qui peuvent se le permettre, qui veulent étudier, ne le peuvent pas
parce que ce n'est pas bien vu,
ce n'est pas la place d'une femme.
C'est le cas d'innombrables femmes
en Afrique par exemple,
privées du droit d'étudier
à cause de barrières culturelles.
La troisième raison :
l'UNESCO a prédit qu'en 2025,
100 millions d'étudiants
seront privés d'éducation supérieure,
tout simplement parce qu'il n'y aura pas assez de places
pour les accueillir, pour répondre à la demande.
Ces étudiants passeront un test de classement,
ils le réussiront, mais ne seront pas admis
juste parce qu'il ne reste plus de place.
Voici les raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai mis sur pied l'University of the People,
une université à but non lucratif, sans frais de scolarité
qui délivre un diplôme,
afin d'offrir une option,
de créer un choix pour ceux qui n'en ont pas,
une option abordable
et modulable,
une option qui va révolutionner
le système d'éducation actuel,
ouvrant la porte à l'enseignement supérieur pour tous les étudiants qualifiés,
sans distinction de revenu, de leur origine,
ou de ce que la société pense d'eux.
Patrick, Debbie et Wael
ne sont que trois exemples
parmis les 1 700 étudiants admis
provenant de 143 pays.
Nous - (applaudissements) - Merci.
Nous n'avons pas réinventé la roue.
Nous avons seulement constaté ce qui ne fonctionnait pas
et avons utilisé le pouvoir incroyable d'internet
pour contourner le problème.
Nous avons cherché à construire un modèle
qui annulerait presque totalement
le coût de l'éducation supérieure.
Voici comment nous y sommes arrivés :
d'abord, les matériaux de construction coûtent de l'argent;
les universités physiques ont des dépenses
que celles en ligne n'ont pas.
Nous n'avons pas besoin d'envoyer la facture à nos étudiants.
Ces dépenses n'existent pas.
Nous n'avons pas à nous préoccuper des places disponibles.
Il n'y a pas de limite de places
dans une université en ligne.
Personne n'a besoin de se tenir debout derrière l'auditorium.
Les manuels scolaires sont aussi
une chose que nos étudiants n'ont pas à se procurer.
En utilisant des ressources en accès libre,
et avec la générosité de nos professeurs
qui mettent leur matériel à disposition gratuitement,
nous n'avons pas besoin de demander aux étudiants d'acheter des manuels.
Toutes les ressources sont gratuites.
Même le salaire des professeurs,
la plus importante charge du budget d'une université,
est offert aux étudiants;
plus de 3 000 d'entre eux,
dont des recteurs, vice-chanceliers,
professeurs et conseillers pédagogiques
des plus grandes universités telles que NYU,
Yale, Berkeley et Oxford
nous ont rejoints afin d'aider nos étudiants.
Pour terminer, nous croyons en l'enseignement par les pairs.
Nous utilisons ce modèle pédagogique sain
pour encourager nos étudiants du monde entier
à interagir et à étudier ensemble
réduisant ainsi le temps
que nos professeurs nécessitent pour la correction.
Si internet a fait de la planète un grand village,
ce modèle peut former ses futurs dirigeants.
Voyons comment nous y arrivons.
Nous n'offrons que deux programmes :
Gestion des affaires et informatique.
Ces deux programmes
sont ceux qui sont les plus demandés dans le monde,
les deux parcours qui aideront
probablement le plus nos étudiants à trouver du boulot.
À l'admission de nos étudiants,
ils sont placés en petits groupes
de 20 à 30 étudiants pour permettre
à ceux qui en ont besoin de recevoir l'attention personnalisée requise.
De plus, à chaque tranche de neuf semaines,
ils font la connaissance de nouveaux pairs,
un tout nouveau groupe d'étudiants de partout dans le monde.
Chaque semaine, lorsqu'ils consultent leur leçon,
ils y trouvent les notes de cours pour la semaine,
les lectures à faire, les devoirs
et la question de discussion, qui est le centre de nos programmes.
Chaque semaine, tous les étudiants
doivent contribuer à la discussion du groupe
et doivent aussi commenter
la contribution des autres.
De cette façon, nous ouvrons leurs horizons,
nous opérons un changement d'attitude positive
face aux différentes cultures.
À la fin de chaque semaine,
les étudiants passent un test,
remettent leurs devoirs,
ceux-ci étant évalués par leurs pairs sous la supervision de l'enseignant,
reçoivent leur note, puis passent à la semaine suivante.
A la fin du cours, ils passent l'examen final,
obtiennent leur note et passent au cours suivant.
Nous ouvrons les portes à l'enseignement supérieur
à chaque étudiant qualifié.
Tous ceux qui ont obtenu un diplôme d'études secondaires,
qui maîtrisent l'anglais et possèdent une connexion internet
peuvent étudier avec nous.
Nous n'utilisons pas d'audio, pas de vidéo.
L'internet à haut débit n'est pas nécessaire.
N'importe quel étudiant de n'importe quelle partie du monde
avec n'importe quelle connexion internet peut étudier avec nous.
Nous sommes exempts de frais de scolarité.
Tout ce que nous leur demandons de couvrir
c'est le coût de leurs examens,
soit 100 dollars par examen.
Un étudiant à temps plein au baccalauréat
qui suit 40 cours,
payera 1 000 dollars par an,
4 000 dollars au total pour leur diplôme,
et pour ceux qui ne peuvent toujours pas se le permettre,
nous offrons un large éventail de bourses d'études.
Nous avons pour mission de ne laisser personne pour compte
pour des raisons financières.
Avec 5 000 étudiants en 2016,
ce modèle est économiquement viable.
Il y a cinq ans, ce n'était qu'une vision.
Aujourd'hui, c'est devenu réalité.
Le mois dernier, nous avons obtenu
l'approbation officielle manquante pour notre modèle.
Les diplômes de l'University of the People sont maintenant pleinement reconnus.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Fort de cette reconnaissance,
c'est maintenant le temps de s’agrandir.
Nous avons prouvé que notre modèle fonctionne.
J'invite les universités et, plus important encore,
les gouvernements des pays en développement,
à adopter ce modèle
afin de s'assurer que les portes de l'enseignement supérieur
soient grandes ouvertes.
Une nouvelle ère débute,
une ère qui verra
se bouleverser le modèle classique de l'éducation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui,
pour passer d'un privilège
à un droit fondamental,
abordable et accessible pour tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)